weil ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen denke ich natürlich
spielte michael hat 10
auf jeden fall jetzt mit dem neuen
system habe ich schon erzählt in der
letzten folge ja ein schuld noch nicht
so schlau so weiter und ich bin nicht so
schnell auf den befehl das wissen leider
war es elf sekunden schaffte jetzt hat
mit dem parcours in dem moment völlig
runter
okay gut kabel machen wir beide treffer
oder wie großen einfach nicht los leider
vor dem spiel ich bin der krankhafter
mein neuer pc
ich habe ihn noch heute steckt mit
initiativ ausgeht die x86 mit vier ja
aber ich habe jetzt noch mal anders
bestellt weil bei den letzten arbeiter
preis irgendwie viel zu teuer bzw
unnötig hoch gepuscht 2000 euro für den
pc und weil man dann hab ich den jetzt
4400 bekommt
er machte das ganze angebot nochmal ein
stücken interessantes bestellt ich habe
nun holzschwerter irgendwas für mich bei
einem unternehmen gefeuert
es war vor ort ich hab da hinter euch
bei dem unternehmen und auch allerdings
aber ich habe auch damit mein bruder
stehe an den links bruder an erinnerte
stadtkyller warst du denn an genauso was
willst du von mir wenn wir finden
einfach alle flash b1 soll jetzt gibt es
jetzt hier
ich habe nur einen freund warst du dabei
sieht man ich bin ich schon immer ich
nicht aber ich muss mein leben aufladen
da musst du echt oder handys in den
obersten richter ich weiß nicht aber ich
will dir nicht will den bist du jetzt
auf einmal hat der kommt hoch ich bin
noch in dem gebäude drin nicht so schlag
als der micha peters ich hab' ich habe
meinem herzen 200 effektgewitter ich
mach das macht das gewächs verbissen
ok ich komme ja aber das war in der
vorrunde erwarte ich warte noch auf den
ok er kämpft kommen in den anderen
später der typ hat stellt jetzt alle
wandert uns alle drei gilt all das
richtig drauf marc lorenz kiss bassist
richtig
hier kämpfen sie bekämpft nicht ganz
weil diese beiden wir gehen ja auf das
um was
nein diese intelligenzbestien hat sich
umbenannt und luca roth 3919 ich kanal
ich habe noch nie gespielt so tritt auch
konnten wir erstmal spielen
ich kann nur einmal wurden zwei gameplay
su ii
so viele leute am trade angegeben okay
das ist schade dass ich nicht weiß ich
bin auch kein schweizer karte der stapel
mir auch nicht also ich das gesagt habe
habe ich auch noch nicht eingegeben
games lp tester alter ja ok mache ich
gehe auch gleich den testern nur die
sache ist die ich habe das genau dann
eingegeben
du wirst mich erstmal runterschubsen
schlecht wird erstmal erschwert haben
ja ich hab 1 aber ich nicht ich bin
hinterher ich bin bei der ich bin kein
trader karte nein ich hab das ding es
nicht detektiv ok gehen wir zum test
kann es eben schwert geben du kannst
redgrave ist tot
alter ich dachte wir sind bloß alter
nicht auf sand ich hab kein foto gemacht
ich wollte mir schwer das alles nicht
wert
ich freue mich dass ihr da hinkommt
zweite sache ich bin trader musicals und
schaffte nicht den sprung zu einer ich
finde ich bin verrückt da habe ich geld
flash b 1
noch anderthalb herzen du das wird jetzt
richtig eng
danach bin ich aber durchaus wieder die
runde welt das ist eigentlich eine ganz
schwierige runde
ja weil ich da schaltet nicht schädigt
sondern so schon aufgebracht ist so
ruhig mal wird man sich nicht
konzentrieren muss ich mal schauen wir
konnten nicht ankommen bist du hast oder
wenn du hast das auch schon als gärtner
dass die gewinne ich weiß ich hab ihn
2345 kammer ich habe nur 10.100 ich war
du hast eine menge gesucht oder
multiplayer lass mal auf elf anlass auf
13 3
1 1 zwischen messen wurzel streiter
wollen wir direkt trader machen
dieser luigi drauf obwohl er habe ich
ihn gekriegt als ich in over hat er mich
einfach gekippt
ja er war aber auch später keine plätze
runter auch aufgenommen und das ehrlich
wenn ich einfach kinder selber schuld
wer mit köhler selber schuld
mama papa und bei diesem gebiet kriegen
kriegen kinder kriegen die schnell
weiter ich habe die sachen die ich
brauche okay bis zu treter ja wäre ich
auch ich nicht weil ich mein ernst ich
hab echt nicht geschafft haben schon
wieder
wir kämpfen jetzt aber nicht direkt hier
nicht direkt gewählt oder doch nicht ich
weiß nicht ich sehe es doch gleich im
chat ja scheiße
bis dann kenne ich dich direkt wenn du
trainer bist wichtig findet mich gar
nicht
dies lockt mit lok er bezeichnet sich
selber als stein nur durch neun stunden
etwas das ich bin ich trainer werden
ich will für kmu abzukriegen genau ich
will auch kinder kriegen er war immer
sein damit er ist jetzt los gegangen ist
von uns gegangen
ich erhielt ihre zum andreas was auf sie
schiessen oft ich weiß ich bin so
schlecht ohne witz leute können aber
auch nicht schießen richtig kribbelig
hier drin ja ihre gebete weg nicht dass
letztlich vielleicht schieße ich bin weg
ich kann auch den kopf ziehen oder durch
wasser konnte ich mit großer mann
zum abschluss gibt's rollende ich sag
schon mal war eine tolle runde mit
kaffee medien und wenn ihr wollt könnt
ihr eine positive bewertung dann lassen
das wird man nicht zum torschuss auf
jeden fall freuen und kabel macht
erstmals einen tollen ton an
da muss ich ganz was auf die app so
lange kann ich euch unterhalten also
soll jetzt muss ich dir denkst du im
moment nur unterhaltung
danach stopp ich direkt die aufnahme
okay leute ich hab euch lieb